I'm very excited for without remorse
where where is that film in the
post-production process we are in
complex Corona post so the director is
in Italy the editor is in Germany we are
here in various places and we Skype
together and we work on the movie
together and then they then we see cuts
and we so we are in the editorial phase
and we're actually doing when we
actually get it all week this um we've
been doing it all week this week in the
mornings so four time zones and it's
going really far better than it should
considering where we all are any Michael
B Jordan is so extraordinary and the
object is very singular in that way it's
kind of a delivery system for this
performance
I like it I think you'll like it I
listen the thing that's fascinating
about that movie is that it's been in
development since um
Sisu feed the meals time on the planet
yes just before actually it started in
at first nobody really almost has right
because the sean ryan draft easy to you
know is exists like jennings you know
was wonderful like there was like this
goes we and I have it I have admired
that project for literally for the
better part of a decade in screenplay ya
know it's been in development since like
nineteen
all kidding us up it's been a long time
I know it has you know look this is a
thing I'm a big fan of this which is I'm
not I'm much less interested in the
fresh new thing because the fresh new
thing is often just yesterday's news
quickly I like the things that have hung
but haven't found their way because
typically they abide with durability
because there's something there so for
me you know I am Legend was set on a
shelf for ten years Hancock which was
tonight he cops was around for ten years
even deep blue sea these are things that
I value these objects that people have
affection for but haven't quite been
able to crack and so too is without
remorse there there's Marion these
things that we don't forget yeah well
they're it's sticking around like that
generally there's something to it